hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that takes artistic
achievement and tosses it into a pit
from which only one movie franchise
character and we have animals at one
point emerges winners i think a video
game once one time today's competition
is unlike any other and i'll tell you
why it's because we're featuring a smash
shot between four different iterations
of the same character relax batman take
five superman y'all are great thanks for
all the lives you saved but right now in
the spotlight it's the incredible hulk
also known as hulk or dr banner bruce
sometimes david david bruce or if you
know him well enough big guy hey big guy
he's also saved tons of lives fought on
a team known as the avengers and has
racked up the largest cleanup bill in
earth history but hey that's why we pay
taxes all four primary players of bruce
banner slash the hulk will be competing
today and from the pile one will be
crowned champion and advance to play the
jolly green giant in the next round in
one corner we have lou ferrigno who
popularized the comic book character in
the 1970s on the incredible hulk tv show
and the only one of our competitors to
not borrow cgi to enhance his biceps far
out in the next corner it's eric bona
who appeared in the 2003 angley-directed
the hulk film five years later that hulk
would be reinvented to be incredible
once more and enter the mcu that version
was played by edward norton who was then
replaced by our still current hulk mark
ruffalo that guy's brain is a bag full
of cats he could smell crazy on him lots
of acting chops and abs amongst these
four fellows and they really make you
believe that purple pants could be that
stretchy can i smell stretchy
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
cultural relevance round four
highlander and then we'll do a wild card
round that sounds redundant because in
every round we have multiple
incarnations of a guy who turns into a
huge green wild animal but lately he's
not only been domesticated he's actually
willing to take selfies with astonished
fans say green
green
the character was the co-creation of
writer stan lee and artist jack kirby
and for all the love that we rightfully
give lee for his tremendous cameos in
the mcu flicks did you know jack kirby
cameoed in the no escape episode of the
1970s tv program and that was decades
before the futuristic dystopian ray
liotta prison movie no escape came out
jack kirby well ahead of his time well
my heart rate's starting to climb so
it's high time to get this show on the
road before i bust my way out of the
studio and pile on sokovia let's get it
on round one box office i just realized
that i'm screwed regardless of who wins
this matchup because every actor that
plays the hulk is either bigger than me
taller than me arguably handsomer than
me or can back squat my house so a
special apology to lou ferrigno just in
case this round doesn't go to you we
don't have a ton of ratings data from
the 1970s to pump up his claim to round
one but i'll tell you what i am going to
do he gets a quarter of the credit from
the incredible hulk's box office for
that stellar cameo and he's also great
in i love you man as himself so i'm
going to add that box office total of 93
million dollars to his earnings here it
still might not matter in fact i have a
feeling that lou edward and eric are all
gonna be duking it out for second place
in round one why the [ __ ] would anyone
get in a fight with lou ferrigno but
we'll honor the spirit of any given
sunday where special players make
special plays and upsets can happen
could it be a big upset w for the hulk
from 2003 well despite it failing to
launch a franchise of its own it still
grows 245 million dollars worldwide so
that's a big number to topple then in
2008 the incredible hulk got a big boost
from the runaway success that was iron
man blasting the mcu into the
stratosphere and the big fella consumed
265 million in popcorn munchies but
that's the only outing that norton and
bonna had as the famous green alter ego
lou ferrigno however what he lacks in
box office he makes up for with made for
tv movies now relegated to the hallmark
channel during the season of giving but
back in the day movies on tv were all
the rage you wouldn't like me when i'm
angry that rage was literal when it
comes to lou ferrigno films starting out
with an origin story movie in 1977 that
accompanied the hit tv show which would
finally end its run in 1982. then from
1988 to 1990 we were treated to a
trilogy of hulking the return the trial
and the death of the incredible hulk if
only they got a big screen release but
even all the nielsen boxes in the world
wouldn't have been enough to take this
round from mark ruffalo who made his
debut as hulk with a tiny little 2012
movie called the avengers an avengers
movie has never made less than 1.4
billion dollars worldwide and that low
bar if we can even call it that was set
by age of ultron the og avengers movie
held in 1.5 billion infinity war raked
in over 2 billion and end game was just
shy of 2.8 billion dollars stating a
good case for being the highest grossing
picture ever if you still like math
here's some more advanced calculus
ruffalo appearances as the hulk total
8.62 billion dollars aided by thor
ragnarok and he averages 1.7 billion
dollars every time he splits his pants i
know the 2003 film has its supporters i
really like the 2008 version and lou
ferrigno is the actual embodiment of the
character but mark ruffalo is over here
making scrooge mcduck look like a
peasant he takes the round convincingly
and gets a one point lead over his
fellow hulksters i smashed you yeah sure
round two tomato meter slash audience
score you know for a guy who's already
on substances banned by professional
sports leagues or maybe it's the gamma
rays that keep tom brady so youthful
it's almost as though the mark ruffalo
hulk is on double steroids thanks to his
being in the mcu it wasn't a whole
cinematic universe yet when edward
norton accidentally tainted some soda
and eric bonas hulk emerged when we were
still figuring out how to make these
comic books into lasting big screen
properties bonna and norton only have
one shot in this round as they were only
in one film as a version of the hulk
each and ferrigno has plenty of small
screen achievements but can that
translate to tomato meter success it's
time for an executive decision to level
the playing field in this round i will
attempt something never before seen on
versus as the host i am judge jury and
judy of this contest so i propose a hulk
team up for this round only it's mark
ruffalo and his film says hulk versus
the combined might of all three
opponents enemies will become friends
and if they defeat ruffalo each of them
are going to get a point and we'd all be
tied up
that's gonna be easier said than done
however because these marvel cinematic
now multiverse movies tend to at least
do well with the fans and usually the
critics too so we'll start with the hulk
from 2003 and the news is good in the
tomato meter because we got freshness
thanks largely due to velvet revolver on
the soundtrack that film rested 62
percent on the tm and then edward norton
upped the ante all the way up to 67 for
the incredible hulk why is that always
considered one of the weakest mcu movies
i liked you good that's good and now the
disappointing news lou ferrigno's
hulking didn't register as fresh in the
veggie patch and as the tv movies
continued they got more rotten by the
time the death of the incredible hulk
dropped in 1990 it was down to 20
percent the audience score does improve
for lou as he can boast about a 53
average for all of his hulking and tv
episodes and movie events edward norton
also improves with the good folks of
earth up to 70 percent so we're looking
strong here oh no eric banas the hulk
just didn't connect with fans the same
way it did with critics and the 2003
venture is only at 29 on the audience
score did you people not appreciate both
nick nolte and jennifer connolly in one
movie together
so all told we toss all three actors
into a vitamix it makes a smoothie that
is borderline fresh for its averages but
the bar has been set not particularly
high enough for mark ruffalo but still
this is why you play the games and now
the ruffalo hulk will treat his brethren
about as nicely as he did loki at the
end of the first avengers movie puny god
the big guy's worst output still would
have been the best score for any of his
three competitors that was age of ultron
and it's residing at 76 percent fresh in
the tomato meter and 82 percent for the
audience score from there it's all sunny
skies as end game is the high mark on
the midter day tomato at 94 percent and
infinity war and the og avengers are
tied for the audience top score at 91
and the average is well they sing the
same song ruffalo is at an 88
on both metrics so if you like
numerology have at it and it appears the
mark ruffalo really likes winning he
just added another point by taking this
round and suddenly he's on the verge of
a skunk it's two for him
zip for everyone else hey big guy angry
girl what have you been up to
winning round three cultural relevance
finally a break for the earlier hulks
mark ruffalo has had the luxury of
entering a company on the second floor
as the elevator was shuttling at light
speed into the cosmos but laying the
groundwork for his emergence was three
predecessors who all can claim a
significant measure of cultural
influence lou ferrigno birthed the fella
in three dimensions eric bana helped
pave the way for future comic book films
and edward norton nurtured the mcu
before we ever had met thor captain
america or black widow back in 2003 we
were cooking with a few popular comic
book properties that were flapping their
wings into full-fledged franchises
spider-man and the x-men and a little
bit of blade were in the midst of
setting the template for future
characters to follow the hulk won't ever
be confused as mighty as those other
flicks but it was impactful nonetheless
the cgi was a step forward at the time
and when the trailer hit during the
super bowl it said records when the
internet was still that thing that took
insanely long to buffer iron man
happened in the summer of 2008 and was a
revelation the anticipation was somewhat
but the end result was magic and the
word of mouth started to spread that we
have a new player in tony stark who's so
cool suave and magnetic we could really
build a whole universe with this dude
but you need help and edward norton's
incredible hulk was rubber-stamped as a
charter avenger thanks to the
post-credits scene that he wasn't even
in tony stark shows up to pound a few
beverages with general ross and the rest
is history if ruffalo does have a leg to
stand on here it's got to be how his
hulk has shown the audience the trauma
that one should endure if they get on
the wrong side of experimental
technologies sure it's fun to smash
stuff but we also see the human cost of
not being able to control oneself
innocent folks get caught in the midst
of a jolly green rage and dr banner is
left to wrestle with the aftermath his
depression is noted repeatedly
throughout the mcu flicks and it always
feels like an important message without
being overly preachy but if you're
singing the gospel of the incredible
hulk it's always going to start with lou
ferrigno when he auditioned for the role
on a whim he was busy training for the
1977 mr olympia bodybuilding contest he
booked the role and before we continued
with his lineage the ultimate winner of
that 1977 match was not arnold
schwarzenegger he did win every year
from 1970 1975 and then again in 1980
but in 77 it was robbie robinson taking
the over 200 pound title the more you
know
[Music]
[Applause]
meanwhile on tv hulk was a sensation
pioneering makeup and camera tricks
delighted audiences that had grown up as
first generation incredible hulk
enthusiast remember the character had
debuted only 15 years prior to the tv
show and although its run ended in the
early 80s the movies continued into the
1990s and it was always ferrigno flexing
for the cameras but perhaps the biggest
impact lou had is also the most obvious
dude was actually that huge every other
hulk was almost all cgi that stuff
wasn't around back when fleetwood mac
was having too much fun in the studio so
you had to be meticulous in casting they
knocked it out of the park with both
bill bixby and lou ferrigno and the fact
that ferrigno maintained hulk's shape
for almost 15 years is remarkable but
actually have you seen the guy recently
i think he still can suit up for another
season stop calling me hulk i'm a person
okay the history of the incredible hulk
is a tale well told by four very
different yet all-accomplished thespians
but on page one it's lou ferrigno as the
perfect embodiment of that alter ego of
course a big shout out to bill bixby for
playing dr david bruce banner it's the
best combo role since david prowse and
james earl jones teamed up to play that
really bad father in a galaxy far far
away ferrigno gets the w here and is on
the board but ruffalo still has the lead
by a point round four highlander no none
of these dudes have been in a highlander
movie yet and sadly that universe
doesn't have much hope of ever crossing
over with the mcu
i know you'd pay to watch it so would i
we'd all pay money but that doesn't mean
we can't borrow an all-time movie quote
from highlander and incorporate it into
this incredible versus episode seriously
it is going to be legal to do this i
asked my lawyer who happens to be a hulk
her damn self just want to be a normal
anonymous lawyer i'm excited about
she-hulk the quote is there can be only
one and it applies to this round thusly
one flick from each competitor will be
accepted as your best work and then it's
going to be that one movie that dukes it
out against the fellow best of the best
for eric bond and edward norton film
selection is going to be a pretty easy
task they each have one hulk movie in
their filmography so that's what we're
going to go with the hulk and the
incredible hulk choice matters when it
comes to ferrigno and ruffalo or as i
call them
fera floccano
for lou let's saddle him with the 1977
the incredible hulk tv movie that acted
as a pilot for the ensuing series run
and for ruffalo i'm gonna go with the
lesser appreciated avengers movie age of
ultron why well he's a great side
character in the avengers has some epic
highlights and is the comedic relief of
thor ragnarok what are you crazy yes
okay he's one of many comedic reliefs
and thor ragnarok and as for infinity
war and endgame well he's only really
hulk for end game and it's such a
stacked card that no one individual can
stand out but in age of ultron we get it
all a fun opening adventure the
hulkbuster fight the aftermath that
reveals the tortured soul of dr banner
and some real hard questions posed by
the film in regards to the human cost of
being a world saver if ferrigno won the
cultural relevance round and he did
well done lou then you'd have to
consider his inaugural entry into the
world as a valid contender and as a
story it does hold up quite well we're
introduced to banner as he's dreaming
about losing his wife in a car accident
a reality that he must wake up to every
morning further frustration lies in his
not being able to summon super strength
despite testing some gamma radiation on
himself that is until he gets angry with
card trouble during a lightning storm
and it happens the incredible hulk
appears and the rest is history
if aang leaves the hulk won't go down as
a great film it should at least be
remembered as an ambitious effort lee
himself was hot off the rousing success
achieved by crouching tiger hidden
dragon and he looked at this hulk story
as one that focuses on how strained
familial ties can affect us far more
than appearances can intimate here it's
the inner turmoil that causes a hulking
out episode and then we also have that
military angle that allows us to witness
hulk toss tanks like their softballs
over a canyon it's fun stuff there were
similar elements of militaristic control
and psychodrama stemming from the failed
experiment in 2008's the incredible hulk
but the film plays much more as a solid
origin story a foundation from which a
wealth of stories could spring even if
the ensuing tales would be told by a
different actor playing dr banner hulk
but if ruffalo had the advantage of
building off of norton's hard work he
forgets the cardinal rule of this show
the host really likes a good origin
movie i mean really likes it so here we
meet banner as a man without a home as
he's been holed up in various locations
dodging the might of the united states
army he doesn't want to be all that he
can be he wants to go back to who he
used to be but soon enough he's
discovered and pursued by general ross
who happens to have a daughter that
banners sweet on and then a more
sinister presence appears a soldier
desperate to stay relevant on the
battlefield who will do anything to
transform from a guy who looks
remarkably like tim roth into
abomination and that might be the
separation the 2008 flick needs to get a
w here the struggle of banner hulk is
well told in each iteration but it
wasn't until this version that we were
treated to a brawl echoing shades of
godzilla tussling with king kong we're
rooting for norton to get a breakthrough
that's finally gonna heal him all the
while keeping our fingers crossed for a
showdown for the ages with hulk smashing
stuff against abomination it's a largely
forgotten building block of the mcu but
here it finally gets its run the
incredible hulk from 2008 scores its
first point of the day and cuts the lead
of ruffalo again to one
and now it's time for the wild card
round iconic moments now finally we get
to celebrate all the destruction the
carnage the wrecked cities the
occasional building accidentally falling
on someone's head the exciting moments
that we love about hulk in any
generation and just for funsies to make
it as hotly a contested matchup as
superhumanly possible hulk team up yup
i'm pinning ruffle against his three
combatants once again making two teams
that are actually pretty even in this
deciding round
eric bana is our only green lug that
hasn't scored a point yet even though he
might be the most gigantic hulk of the
four in contention nick nolte pitches in
well too as the hulk vs dad fight is a
highlight and yes any time you gamma-ray
a poodle i'm gonna keep watching the
movie hulk tossing tanks and playing
with missiles is also a good time and
who knew that he could leap like that
it's super athletic for being that big
but mark ruffalo can counter here with
just the avengers if he wasn't the
biggest piece of that puzzle he was
definitely the most enjoyable
smash
while tony and cap have a contest
involving bathroom stalls and black
widow and hawkeye have some nice moments
it's hulk who shows up and delivers in
the clutch more than anyone else he
saves iron man's tookus during the
battle of new york then he cuts off loki
mid-sentence by tossing him around like
my dog would a new toy oh and the
scrimmage against thor the casual
knocking out of frame of thor by hulk
works visually and comedically
the battles and personal anguish rage on
an age of ultron but sometimes it's the
quiet scenes that are the most iconic
just ask the og incredible hulk
hitchhiking as we end an episode hoping
to just stay even keel a lonely man who
knows he can't stay in one place for too
long lest he fight every bull across the
country seriously that cannon features a
great contest against the bull well
somebody tell me what the hell is going
on here edward norton's hulk gets a
climactic heavyweight bout worth the
build up but the chase scene when the
government first locates him might be
the best of the bunch the look on tim
ross face as he sees the impossible
inside of a soda bottling plan is a mix
of terror and i found my purpose and the
sequence is riveting but the marvel
cinematic universe loves two things
above all others moments of levity and
epic battles and ruffalo gets to
participate in both as we clean up a
decade of greatness with avengers end
game the final battle moments will
obviously live on in comic book film war
for ages and we also have a hulk under
control of his powers who's even willing
to say hi to adoring fans as he takes
down a stack of flapjacks even in
infinity war when the whole turning
green thing has been so stifled below
sea level that banner can't summon him
even when he needs to works for both
humor and suspense purposes but if it's
comedy and action you like look no
further than thor ragnarok thor being
tossed into the pit against his friend
from work is just such a good time it's
a feast for the senses and the funny
bone and a petulant toddler brand hulk
works for both hahas and proving this
guy can actually develop into an actual
person one day that could control that
anger and harness the full potential of
the gamma radiation without all those
pesky downsides even teamed up as one
giant unit ferrigno banna and norton
just don't have the juice to take down
the spoil of riches bestowed upon us by
ruffalo's iteration
[Music]
the current hulk wins the iconic moments
round and thus takes the match i feel
really good about this ruling simply
because all four of our competitors
they're not gonna remember any of this
i'm sure they're watching but tomorrow
they're gonna wake up in the woods
shirtless with shredded pants and wonder
what the hell happened it's gonna be our
little secret because i don't want to
make any of them angry and once again
it's worth remembering that we don't get
any of these hulks without the genius of
stan lee and jack kirby and bill bixby
and lou ferrigno pioneering the way for
all to follow and as always this is just
my opinion now it's your turn earthlings
hit me up on social media with your take
at mark ellis live and defend your
choice with vigor and make sure you keep
it tuned right here to rotten tomatoes
for all the latest in the realm of
movies tv and any other place where a
hulk might show up thanks for watching
versus i'm your host mark ellison yes i
will be hitchhiking home
[Music]